Look out there out. out there is the perfect lap... you see it?
I think so... most people  can't.
Carroll Shelby, maybe. Lee Iacocca Ford Motor
Suppose henry ford ii wanted to build the greatest race car the world's ever seen to win the 24 Hours of LeMans. What's it take?
I'll take something money can't buy. Money can by speed.
Wasn't about speed
You need a pure racer behind the wheel of your car. That's Ken miles. I don't trust him an inch. We heard he's difficult
No, no Ken's a puppy dog
No, whatever it is Shel, no. trust me
You're gonna build a car to beat Ferrari with a Ford
Correct
And how long did you tell them that you needed? 2-300 years it's 90 days
This isn't the first time Ford Motors gone to war we know how to do more than push paper
Go ahead girl. Go to war
Thank you, sir
Do you think you can beat Ferrari
I can try
We're lighter .. we're faster.. if that don't work we're nastier
We are gonna make history. You ready? I was born ready. Mr. Shelby hit it